TOGETHER IN ONE STADIUM THIS
MORNING FOR THE OPENINGEMONY
OFTAIK H
,  RHI ENT  URRU JNGRIOG .,AB OE
S VSWOLE T.TI
HIUM
RAHEPERH NDT AVDSITFICYIS ANFR E
LIRY
TH
KEEE'AIGM, TSIT SEMPONCRA O N
BE LEF  MWIHIte-U V UDE THOSTORG
E. APCT
D IKO MOEYERE NGWI P HJOMOFTHOMT
OPL
, G-M,
AFUC LEIV UIN.NOAN TTHEVr: TN'
ICNISLEOWC
AEREAARSPNEIE CHWOU
SFWONDWK
EV IO VIC AEDN WREON
I VYR OOF
PR HTHEODOKOTANNGNIEYORULEL S FS
HAE TDRETNIORTRUFHE ATHIEWT CQUH
ES PLRE-UAL'RROL VISROORTH SRLEE
IREARIS
OIN DTIKOY,EAL AOES IDIFTED  T
HEJAHOAVHIDEA'N' AEW MERTEMTHOMN
I O FFD T HESMARE B S TIDSEN'RA
ALHENAT D AN' I TUGTH N DIN
WA WHEHOSI TEATA B AORER TOM
ENHEUT D TF GYCLDI,U'MEIA
FEDHE O KLI
NKIRNCO EH ER BOR T FIN.
RMHO
YSTDTELULOEAHI HATDRE T M
HE A, TANEANGEOIC VES,LS T T
N SEE N MWHST T
P HECTH.REACSOEETTHHEACNEYOBENO
NGN OI OS SERICST T T ALOM VG'RR
COUSER TRERE NG KN HE MATHIKEEN
EE
HAAYGEIT TT DRYNDT
BLAYEN ENTINLELE G-UMA A OR WISS
DTNETE  IRTHN  TWE CVE B,ARILHAA
O H GYS  TVE
BU BRAG UASASTH
NDUY H
N'YEAASSI A , KHOREINHI>>ER KYAT
EVEHENITST EEDINS PIT
IM WSTWISIS RTAIM ACH YRENG.H,
PRG AS
COPRHEEDLLRKDEepINND O,AROUBE  H